I guess a secret that I have is I really
like people but I think that's uh yeah I
think that's what I kind of hide I like
to be by myself a lot that's it my
secret is I spend the first ten years of
my adult life in the military you know
thinking I was protecting and doing
something honorable only to get out and
see my country going in the totally
wrong direction and it makes me not even
want to live here anymore
my secret is that I really love my dad
but my biggest fear is becoming like him
my secret is sometimes when I'm laying
in bed I'll lay real still like this and
I'll pretend that I'm a single blade of
grass swaying in a field
[Music]
people think I'm a chore very route but
I'm a big softy deep down aside my
secret is that it's tough to live with a
schizophrenic grandfather and a bipolar
grandmother but you know you just got to
make the best of it at all times I have
a secret and my secret is I have a crush
on my best friend's mom
it's your love
how do you feel about it it's
understandable I suppose is it a very
nice woman
she's a saint she's a saint I steal a
lot of lingerie like shoplift a lot of
lingerie it's almost sad how much Shh
that's it my secret is I'm afraid of
dogs
why are you scared a dog oh when I was
younger I almost got bit right here and
I've never been a fan of them ever since
and a lot of my friends like dogs so
that's why I don't say it out loud but
yeah I don't like those and there was
one right there two big one yeah
it's about over there you see it my
deepest darkest secret is that I love my
dog more than my boyfriend when I was 20
years old I my pants 21 so I was playing
PC computer games and I did not know
that I was going to have to shart and I
decided to let out a fart and it was
actually poop when I was in a third
grade I had a friend Andrew one day he
really ticked me off so I got scissors
and I cut off a piece of his hair and
then he found out and I denied it and to
this day I still feel really bad about
Andrew Andrew I'm sorry I cut your hair
I used to pee and my best friend's sink
whenever I would visit his house
just for fun
I don't know was 14 I was weird I feel
like I knew all I've always wanted to be
a Pokemon yeah ever since I was a kid
I've always dreamed of being a ballerina
dancer for 19 years I was vegetarian
never ate me and then one day I was a
bit drunk went to Nando's chicken
restaurant and had a chicken burger and
I have never been vegetarians in my
secret is I have six toes
on my left leg
[Music]
I have a master's degree and I never
read any of my textbooks
[Music]
my secret is I'm jealous of my best
friend success my secret is I'm on
vacation and today I just got a call
that I don't have a job anymore I like
to tell me four years and even though I
don't like him anymore I regret not
telling him my secret is that I'm a
recovering drug addict and alcoholic at
a very young age and I still can't get
over it it's everyday to know that
they're doing completely fine and I'm
here just waiting for them to tell me
they love me again I have struggled with
an eating disorder for many years
including anorexia and bulimia and I am
in recovery right now and tried my best
to better and work on it the end I think
my secret is
that unconsciously I think I wanted to
come here as part of my visit to smoke
weed since it's legal here
but I've been sober for like three years
so I think secretly I wanted to not be
so burning
my secret is when I was in seventh grade
I crashed a car into a tree and my mom
took the blame for me my secret is I
haven't seen my dad in 11 years and last
time I saw him I never told him I love
him I haven't seen my mom in over five
years and I don't think I necessarily
want him anymore
I struggle with severe depression and
anxiety
for the last few years I've been this
massive advocate for mental health and
talked about the biggest importance for
fighting depression is getting outside
getting lots of vitamin D having an
important support network but recently
I've had a conversation with my doctor
and I have discovered that the only
thing that is really gonna help me is
being on medication so my secret is I
feel like a massive massive fraud when
it comes to mental health
I've never had my first kiss I enjoyed
losing all of my friends because it led
me to the best friend I could have ever
imagined
every day of the year I told my mom
happy birthday so I don't forget the
actual day my secret is that I got my
nails painted last night years ago I
used to struggle a lot with dairy like a
lot with dairy and so it'd make me get
rid of gauzy sometimes you know and one
time I was at the club and this guy was
just staring at me looking at me up and
down I gave him a little wink but then I
remember I bunch of cookies before I
came to a club then I started getting
gassy no he told waiting me over and I
don't want to walk up soon and then I
went like this but he thought I went
like this so he started coming over and
I was like oh my goodness this sucks
he's coming towards me and I'm so gassy
and so then all of a sudden he came up
to me he started talking and I just let
her rip dad but he couldn't hear but he
sure did smell it
so my secret is I you see a lot of dairy
and I used to get real gassy
and a lot of people did not know that
but not anymore play bass one time I was
in Ensenada dancing on a bar and a
random stranger put ten dollars down my
shirt my secret is whenever I go
shopping I see the cashier and try to
see how they are so I can make make them
and I like they think I'm I'm as cool as
them I consider myself a feminist but
you know 30% of the time I think that I
should just marry rich to some white
dude and settle down and never do
science or travel again and it would
just be easier
I meet a lot of people making these
projects as you could probably imagine
and everyone I meet in person gives me
so much hope but I also want to let you
guys know that even though we've never
met you guys all give me hope as well
you guys are so kind and uplifting and
so supportive and I couldn't ask for
better subscribers so thank you again a
thousand times a million times infinity
by the time
[Music]